what's the biggest bet you ever played
500 grand 500. what was the game what
was that i was i did a bunch it was uh
i went through a stretch
i don't know college football is up i
was probably i mean i was betting it
every game i know which one i lost which
stopped it was virginia tech uh north
carolina this dude brandon walker jinxed
it but yeah
wait what do you mean he jinxed it he he
he changed the vibes now
i took the
when someone bets that much yeah and
like
it was virginia tech had come back taken
a lead and then
two people got in a fight they stopped
watching the game like no concentrate
concentrating as i said it the big play
happened changed the vibes no um yeah i
think if i bet that i've done that a
bunch that's the biggest i bet prior to
that i had bet 250 grand on the pats to
win the super bowl against the rams and
i that i was in jail for it i think
that's the game i got dragged out so i
had no idea what was going on i could i
could hear the crowd but i couldn't i
didn't cause you're in the stadium i was
in the stadium jail yeah
yeah wow how is that by the way it it
was horrible they and then they walked
me out in handcuffs
and walked me like probably i don't know
half a mile away from the stadium and i
turn on the phone with no idea what
happened in the game like i knew it was
over but i didn't know anything about it
that's a rush why they like you uh so i
was banned like i have a i'm a patriot
fan uh and i have a thing with roger
goodell the nfl commissioner so a thing
uh uh a real beast we protest brady got
suspended for four games
i went to nfl
we headquarters ourselves to each other
four of us in nfl headquarters demanding
to talk to goodell and we got uh put in
jail for night so that happened and that
launched
to this day
uh an ongoing rivalry with him so i'm
banned
from the from the super bowl because nfl
event so i went in bought a ticket i had
a ticket and they dragged me out in
halftime they put me in handcuffs they
literally dragged me out like i went
dead fish like i mean like yeah like
five security guards like pick me up and
drag me out who are you with at the game
one of my got one of my guys he videoed
it was all patriot fans too and then
they tried to kick me out of the post
game
i've won a raffle during covid yeah this
is this is
paid 250 grand to watch monday football
with goodell oh wow and they uh then
they contact me like we've done research
on your file and you're not eligible
it's like my file is basically just me
being arrested at nfl headquarters i
don't know how much research you had to
do for that um so yeah that's why but i
watched that game without no i could
hear crowd noise and no one would tell
me what the [ __ ] was going on i'm like
what's going on what's going on also the
cops that weren't even nobody told there
was no around no phone no nothing was
there anyone else in the cell with you
like anyone else that they got arrested
at the game no oh no it's just me it was
just me it was actually
weird because not weird the nfl was who
put me there and this was also
must have been like very high security
for terrorism and the face recognition
the atlanta cops
like when they found out
what was going on they were livid at the
nfl oh you're wasting our time with this
guy because they're they're on full
alert for like major [ __ ] right not a
guy who is protesting tom brady being
suspended like why why they they had
like because the nfl
had security draw dragged me out then
they called over like 10 cops and the
cops like wait what what's going on what
what's the problem like yeah he's a
patriot fan like that was what i was
being basically dragged out it was
interesting
[Applause]
you